[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to GameSpot live we
are playing code veins network test
Jordan and I have been playing around
with it so we figured what the heck we
might as well do some co-op and show you
guys what it's like I'm gonna have some
help this time I struggled with neo but
maybe with a partner I can actually beat
this soul's like or beat this dungeon
that we found herself in yeah this has
been it's kind of an interesting setup
right because the the network test opens
with you creating your character and
then you play a short single-player
section and then it throws you into if
you want to play multiplayer you have to
do a level 40 co-op done or a level 40
dungeon which is kind of ridiculous also
I just realized we don't have chat up so
I'm gonna get chat up but anyway yeah
and we started on it I you were but I
was level I want to stay maybe like 10
or 11 something like that so we went
into like the very first room and just
got annihilated yeah like the very first
enemy isn't like are we are we doing
something wrong this doesn't seem right
give me one second while I get chat up
here no you may have 10 seconds
I remember is all of our network
sightings from yesterday hopefully it
does I make this a little bit bigger
because I'm blind
okay anyway my distress signal alright I
will join you might notice that I have
zero haze that's this game's version of
like Dark Souls is souls or blood echoes
or whatever it's because Jake and I
found a boss it's essentially in
Ornstein and smile situation where
there's two of them and we have not been
able to beat them and so my forty
thousand haze it's just yeah there
Matthew pace also says you can level up
faster the depths yeah that's what we
did we we leveled up pretty quickly it
was just like not really fun I'm just
grinding the same room pretty much over
and over again anyway actually what well
I'm a can't in your game but you can't
look now here we are we're also both
playing on xbox one X so there's that
but yeah if you guys have any questions
anything you want us to try out feel
free to drop it in the chat we'll be
checking that maybe not as frequently as
normal because we're both playing but
I'll definitely be checking that when I
can does have a release window so let's
go this year I love the back doesn't
have a release date don't know how it
does never hurt oh I got a backstab on
the big guy
looks like people have guesses of when
so we're saying August September yeah
it'll probably be fall would be my guess
I'm assuming we're gonna get some sort
of trailer and release date at e3
nothings yeah firmed but if I had to
wait or I guess I mean if I had an
announcement for a game I would probably
a big announcement for a game I'd
probably do it at e3 it would make sense
all right
I don't know run to the right again and
deal with this guy can everybody but we
have not gotten the right angle coming
to us no stop shooting
so much better than I was restarted I
know right although this guy still gives
me a run for my money he still takes out
a chunk do I think cyberpunk will really
released this year yes I do
I have no info I just I just have a gut
feeling that cyberpunk it's coming out
this year or at least they'll announce
it for this year maybe it'll get delayed
it's got to be soon because they said
it's in a playable state they didn't
just save as in a playable state they
said you could play from start to finish
so I imagine this just a matter of bugs
right now mm-hmm
squashing them bugs Sam does not expect
it to be this year that's fair that's
you're probably right that's this is
just me mm-hmm
this is my my hope
oh I'd I'd be revived be revived okay
I'm good
all right we're doing well is there
anything over here here's the gist of
that in it's just in cyberpunk will be
released and forgotten what talking
about this game cuz that's where you're
going
yeah like I said that's do we want to
fight the boss like I said that's just a
guess an uneducated guess to be fair
that's just me hoping that we get it
this year and like it like they didn't
say it's playable from start to finish
so that's gotta mean something what the
heck oh your game just crash yep well I
think we can switch to mine did I do it
I did okay great switch to mine in the
meantime great safe yeah this is a
network test I don't know what this is
alpha or a beta of some sort kind of and
I don't really know but that's the first
crash we've had yeah that's pretty
impressive
we played what three hours or so last
night something like that
first crash between the two of us I was
just on my screen go block for a sec I'm
like are we about to get a cutscene
because we've never gotten a cutscene
for this boss battle before is this game
playable on computer and PlayStation ah
well this network test I think is only
on Xbox and Playstation yeah it's only
on console but it will also the game
will launch on PC as well sometime in
2019 that's all that they've said the
2019 is running out so it's gotta be
soon
once you're ready I can invite you in
the meantime I should probably turn Oh
God
what I get for fooling with the dial pay
attention dodge duck weave
have framerate drops I haven't noticed
any framerate drop however the frame
weight doesn't seem that smooth yeah and
this is like we said Xbox one X is not
4k so I don't think the network test is
enhanced yes probably but you haven't
really experienced framerate job which
is good
no no switch police crime just Xbox one
ps4 and PC all right should I join you
again or do you want to join me whatever
works I can join you this time let's
switch back to your game I'm gonna level
up first - okay
level 43 let's go all right searching
for a distress signal
what's the soundtrack like I haven't
really noticed it hasn't been too
prominent so far in this demo but it
doesn't seem bad Jordan's mics a little
low it is my bad
is that better talk hello hello
hopefully that's better how is loot
shared or completion well we haven't
actually completed this dungeon yet
we're hoping to do it here in terms of
loot it seems like they're identical
every enemy drops the same thing for
both players yeah it's mom and I have
like a son sigh a sunset sword drop on
mine it will also drop from the same
enemy for you yeah
actually tested tested did you not get
it
or am i joining you oh I thought you you
told me to send it okay I can re urgent
okay coming you're confusing me Jake
another thing we found is that whoever
joined some like if I join his game and
I die I won't lose any of my haze or
souls which is why I'm level 46 over 43
and you're not as high I don't think
because we must have been joining his
game alright
it's opener do you have to be invited
you no have I think from from this build
it seems like you have to be search for
someone I don't know if there's any like
invading or anything like that
there's no invasion in code man they
wanted I make an entirely cooperative
like experience you have the npc helper
joining you for most of the game here we
go oh I'm running I just hear his
footsteps
like the abilities you can unlock their
gifts and whatever they're called
they're pretty cool I would say yeah in
this game when you you can basically
change your blood code and that kind of
allows you to just change your class on
the fly and it adjusts all your stats
accordingly so if you're like oh a melee
build isn't really working right now I
want to try more magic base you can just
instantly switch to that and then each
one of the classes has their own unique
set of pretty much just magical and
blood vampire abilities there we go
got a backstab alone so I'm using saw
right now which I keep mispronouncing
every which is just a bill that is good
for melee damage and has a really
explosive magical attacks like
I don't know what you're using right now
by the what one fighter like that no I'm
using I have to look I forget what it
helped yeah
also I'm sure a lot of people in the
chat have already seen this but the
customization in this game is wild yeah
there is you can spend a lot of time in
that it seems like waifu creator 2019 as
i've been calling it of course you
didn't you were like oh no I just used
one of the default models for shame Jake
well shame in a day this character will
cease to exist that's not the point
yeah heading with spells magic
come on don't you shield okay hi Bloxom
having to with that watch your girl says
nice dodge I got this
oh yeah that's a cool one right just
crucifying the person on a bunch of
swords okay let me see what I'm using I
am using prometheus oh the Parry and
dodge focused one yeah yeah the audio is
pretty low oh that's my bad I did that
because we switched to my feet wanted to
go with me alright that seems pretty
loud now
oh I'm back never mind
run away Neal no I'm dead no we must
have used all his revised mark he says
it looks like it looks like souls with
open interconnected areas I don't think
so you kind of have like a hub area that
you go back to it looks like missions
are more standalone yeah I could be
wrong maybe there are areas that are
bigger more complex and open but from
what yeah well there's almost nothing
like we've played a very small slice of
it at the preview event I was talking to
the producer and he described it
similarly to Dark Souls we were
basically traveling from in this game
they're called missiles but basically
bonfires like one to the next and
they're just these interconnected areas
that you just kind of tackle oh they are
connected though the areas are connected
or I'm not what connected I think like
one or two of them are like go back in
on each other but for the most part it's
a very linear experience am i joining
you the same sure senators dress
what we're specifically doing is kind of
like code veins I think their version of
like blood barnes chalice dungeons like
an optional thing you yeah it's not like
random like the childís dungeons but
you're basically just trying to get as
far as you can and there's multiple
directions that you can go in from the
start switch to my feet for this one
should we do we should we go that same
way should we go separate way very
different way we can go to the right
where we're invaded last time by the
NPC's yeah that was weird that hasn't
happened before yeah we got rekt
oh nice weep souls yeah very much
I like this
Prometheus blood teleport move is it
easier than Dark Souls though uh it's
hard to say
oh she get kicked maybe it's hard to say
it doesn't seem like based on the story
stuff it seemed easier but then getting
thrown of this like dungeon thing it was
tougher significantly but we were also
like thirty levels under when we first
came in and now it's not too bad and now
it's plausible
Matthew paced is they always invade the
same spot well they invaded here one
time and they haven't invaded since yeah
but maybe it's because I skipped because
I don't check the chest anymore
oh there we go it's cuz I ran over to
the chest too I'm Deadpool you've
injured them all
I died
[Music]
well that works all right something set
another distress signal I kind of wish
that you could get rid of the NPC and
play with three players I think you can
oh I think you can say no if you see in
the I can check after yeah oh this game
come to PC yep it's supposed to
oh wow got about that guy
there's my souls on my haze all right
so don't go in that corner that's the
last
[Music]
there's a fog wall this way too so this
a different boss entirely are we just
like circling around I don't know but
that's what I was curious about so I
figured we'd head this way no it's not
coming to a switch at least not they've
announced Queen night hey at least
there's only one we have to deal with
yeah and you can definitely tell cuz oh
you died yeah
oh man well good luck Jake can you shoot
can you adjust the sound so they hear
what's happening here
Oh God trying to do multiple things at
once here it's not ideal better no
that's the wrong one no ad it's that one
but I'm dead
yeah distract them
oh my gosh I die immediately now he's
dead switched I should stop switching
it's too stressful we're just gonna
leave it on Jordan's gameplay for now is
this online co-op yep we are playing
online even though we are sitting next
to each other it is online
compared now so you don't regret it
later no this isn't multiplayer only you
do by yourself it's just hard should we
fight the twin bosses twin bosses are
the single boss maybe the twin bosses
cuz we're pretty close to doing that one
I've been having trouble getting used to
the controls like X's light attack why's
heavy attack you hold RB to run which
like for most games I'd be fine though
because it feels so much like Dark Souls
also the gameplay is really loud
let's turn that down
Oh
Oh I thought I could finish him before
that all right I say we ignore the
people to the right I know it's not
public it is a network test you had to
register I think couple weeks ago yeah I
don't really ask anymore yeah should we
yeah students may just beat this boss
Jake I need I just got kicked we don't
have any of these issues last night no
see if I can join again quickly survived
hacker says hey hey how's it going
hacker no distress signals hey because
you're already in a boss fight all mine
ended I would have to send it again I'm
trying to get away from this nope can't
send it okay these are
it's okay you got your buddy he'll heal
you
nope no no no we won't preoccupied hates
me like he says network test is good
news so the game will possibly be out
sooner
I hope so I'm excited to play the full
thing of this it seems to be ready to go
other than the fact that now all of a
sudden we're getting dropped a
multiplayer yeah which is we like like
we should say before we play about three
hours last night didn't have any issues
like this am i sending or searching why
don't you send one and I'll search for
and we'll try that boss again since I
got kicked is it split screen
multiplayer no it's not least I don't
think so
yeah it's like it's very much like Dark
Souls in that you have to invite people
and once you die you're kicked out so
like if you want to play through the
whole game co-op it would probably be
kind of a pain yeah or you could do it
you could do it
magic doesn't have much range in this
game does it no it doesn't have any free
clothes I see some people talk about
dual shockers I have some friends who
work there it's a good place if I should
just ran to the boss huh
probably well easy oh man
MC Armageddon from what I've played it's
quite easy well you are much better than
we are that the the intro area was
really easy
oh yeah the inner area was super easy
this is a little bit more difficult I
can't come in my session is ended it did
it again it was working perfectly fine
I'm gonna look if I can revamp the
controls right now because yeah I don't
I don't care much for the controls
walking does nothing oh you can remap
all the controls it looks like oh so I
can actually put darksouls controls from
this you can the only thing that I'd be
concerned about is the gift stuff
because you have to pull right trigger
it - I'm curious like that would be mmm
difficult okay don't try joining mine I
guess
maybe we can make it to the end
I love that your code name is literally
just code name yeah I forget it all
right should we continue to go this way
should we try different paths we gotta
beat one of these bosses
Oh God you all right over - no
are we gonna make it to the ends I don't
know hopefully not
I just did something that I've never
done before and quite sure what happened
you know and then I'll do stuff like
that you know you can like hold a and do
that attack that like takes extra blood
from people so you can do magic more
easily and stuff like that yeah I did
that with this character with just the
swords coming out of the ground and it
stabbed the person and it sucked them
into the ground it created like this
pool of blood and I could control where
the pool of blood was going but I'm like
I'm not sure what I'm supposed to do
with this interesting all right let's
just run to the boss all right got a new
hammer or a new axe hey nice so now you
have the axe and I have the sword and we
can face I'm nervous to fight the boss
without the swords dude I'm using sort
of so fast oh no wow
that is strange
new gifts new gifts
well I killed one of the bosses
I guess we'll switch I'm gonna die while
I do this
you fool ah that's what gets me I'm
messing with the board everyone's really
lose good sucks try to switch and play
the game that doesn't actually have a
pause but come on
yeah como si you can get him below a
quarter help you'll get further than I
got last night
let me heal dude all right there we go
got'em nice rear loss dispersed all
right easy peasy
did it solo - do you even need can you
play a complete co-op or does it like
darks list uh it seems more except co-op
seems more accessible than Dark Souls
the beginning we couldn't play as co-op
the tutorial and intro looks like you
have to do that
solo other than that it's hard to say
although right now it seems like you
can't play bosses co-op because it keeps
keep getting kicked okay should I I'm
gonna rest and then all invite you again
was there anything beyond that bathroom
or was that that was it I got it so we
need three keys to open this door and I
think I got one of them okay
yes let's just keep joining your game
then and try to get all the keys and
hopefully I don't keep dropping
their rewards for beating the boss's
weapon armor we've only fought one boss
that's the second one that one I got
some stuff I'm gonna say the first boss
that we beat we got his hammer I think
oh yeah you're right you also got his
blood code buzzer ker which allows which
is like for people who want to
specialize in a giant two-handed weapons
and just give up defense participa on
office multiplayer session has ended
just drop it just drop but you're still
searching so I can just join okay this
axe is not compatible with the weapons
I'm using it looks cool
oh it's not very good you need to
upgrade it wow what a worthless
worthless spell that I have unlocked it
literally just makes them marker on the
ground oh nice do not go into the corner
I'm gonna back out of it
gosh is just going for me yep Renzo I
can't pronounce your name but he says
it's time to sleep it's 2 a.m. where is
thank you for streaming like curiosities
have been filled with this you're
welcome thank you for stopping by is
this console only this test is but I
think the the bowl game will come yeah
all right I didn't it didn't kick me
this time keep your fingers crossed that
stays that way yeah oh yeah you guys you
guys fight them all you should take a
step back maybe what's he doing I think
you just got staggered it just tended me
oh you why are you still a feeling I
don't think I can back that move he does
that movie listening for you oh I got to
run run away okay didn't do anything
basically every time you like Oh God oh
he's got new moves oh well I just saw
you disappear in front of my eyes
good luck chick honey players can play
together only two it looks like God
Eater because it was made by the same
folks who made God which is why their
character customization is so
robust combat system good or not uh
depends do you like Dark Souls it's not
as it doesn't seem as polished and as
tight as Dark Souls this gameplay in
combat so that's something to consider
but I don't know it it's flashy yeah
it's fun I died though all right enjoy
switch back to your feed blood-borne
looks better though yeah I mean that
that's a really tough one to beat I'm
gonna go back to home base and see if I
can upgrade some stuff okay now I should
show them what home base looks like
oh we had chat up here that's why I was
wondering why you wanted to bring it up
over there but I'm like I'm not gonna
question it Jake seems to know what he's
doing
oh I think that's from thing that's an
old one I think it isn't but what I can
do is bring juggernaut sledge hammer is
this just anime Dark Souls basically I
mean you're gonna see just how anime in
a second when you see the hub area and
the characters that embody it like the
girl who sells you weapons and stuff
like that has like the highest pitched
voice I don't even have any I lost all
my haze can't really do anything you
could sell any extra stuff that you have
it's true no I just talked to you just
because of course I need something
I know it's a bother but I'll need you
to bring the necessary materials if you
want to upgrade a weapon there's a
shortage of pretty much everything these
days still we're better off than most
people
something
is anything new to body no no there's
not
all the blood whales are not it's so
good upgrade I can upgrade my sword once
more queen Slayer blade +2
and I have 13 days I probably can't do
anything
how many players could play together I
think it's only two can you beat the
beta I mean we beat the story stuff in
the beta this is post stuff we haven't
beaten it so yeah the loading screens
are so long yes they are that is
something we have definitely noticed
looks like you can use that heel upgrade
thing in home base to wear no you just
go to your inventory and use it
oh and now I've got four regen things
God Eater yep as Jordan was saying it is
made by the same developers as God Eater
running at 60fps on console or PC
this is console it doesn't look like
60fps also keep in mind that just cuz
the stream doesn't look 60fps doesn't
mean that our feed isn't necessarily oh
you can sit just like have a close-up of
your character I feel like I'm trying to
like eavesdrop on people or something
what are the system requirements I don't
know
and terms of release state release date
is 2019 so fall hopefully maybe like
late summer to give you all an idea of
the character customization options
oh yeah it's probably a good idea so
here's all the different skin tones and
stuff like that that you can do in each
one of those little squares then there's
a bunch of different hairstyles this is
a true story yeah a true story with
highlights that you can do there are a
bunch of different eyes that you can do
different pupil colors there are like 30
different eyebrows no like 50 or 60 no
there's a lot of eyebrows
there's makeup scars and all that good
stuff face paint accessories and when
you can equip up to eight accessories at
one time there are a bunch of clothing
options
well a few casual clothing options
you can decide what mask you wear when
you go into the infected areas as well
as the frame for your mask when you're
not wearing it and yeah so I spent like
a good 3035 minutes on this last night
and then I texted Jake I'm like oh so
where are you and he's like oh I'm at
this one I'm like okay you're like way
past me already in the tutorial area
please wait for me and if you want you
can see the types of expressions your
character can make and have them pose in
different ways
and then change the background and then
exit out take a screenshot someone asked
if you can switch it between male and
female yes okay are you actually to show
what the male options look like no no
like can you just like switch any time
or is I think you might be stuck yeah
depending on what you choose the
beginning maybe there's ways to change
later in the game but I and say that was
locked and there was something else that
I can't remember now that when I
selected it it like reminded me in the
top right corner it's like just so you
know once you start playing you can't
change this but everything but yeah you
can change for free right doesn't cost
any haze or anything yeah yeah so just
do whatever
alright should I join your game when you
ready how does it game feel compared to
Dark Souls it doesn't feel as good I
will say Dark Souls feels a little a
little tighter a little more precise
this works but like I don't know
sometimes when you attack the enemies
it's hard to tell if they're like
recoiling from it
some of the animations are a little
strange sometimes I'll I'll think I
dodged in time but I won't it's not like
Dark Souls where you can clearly see the
moment you're supposed to dodge so then
it's kind of hard to tell like I mean
even if you still get hit and Dark Souls
usually you can still be like oh that is
the moment I should have rolled with
this it's terrible but this is closer to
the how the original Dark Souls played
it's not like Dark Souls 3 and blood
where the hitboxes are very precise yeah
so not terrible
it could be better am i joining you is I
we said sure I have sent a distress
responded she looks like a tea and Chie
from soda for
what kind of weapons do they have so far
I have only found Queen Slayer blades
which are very like your average normal
blade as well as bayonets and heavy axes
and then I found a hammer but looking at
this it looks like the only other one
that I haven't found is a heavy blade
and some sort of pike type axe so it
looks like there's five different types
of weapons to go down the normal way no
I went to the way we never got alright
oh I'm getting getting racked at the
moment all right geez that whole thing
just frozen there oh that probably is
why oh dang well then maybe I should
join your game since the feed is on you
and I don't wanna keep switching between
feeds but you're the one who's actually
beaten
what do we think of the rumor of jr.
Martin
grr Martin consulting from software in a
game I mean there seems to be a lot of
rumor springing up to be the case so I
would believe it and he writes books
that are very similar to the stories
that from software creates so I could
totally see it happen
yeah I'd be I'd be I've statement I'll
play any from software game but most
film software games this game ranges
from very quiet to really loud have
microtransactions like loot boxes if
they do they're not in this I don't
think so
I haven't seen any all these guys hurts
that's smarts
you make range builds not really it
seems like there are a lot of like
spells rave spells but they don't go all
that far yeah and sorry lot of enemies
right now I wish that there was more
range objects threat it seems very melee
focused oh I got a new sword this is a
dead end
it's nothing in this direction
I hope they do bloodborne to soonish I
hope so too
that's what we thought sakura is going
to be at first in that very first teaser
when it was just a close-up of what we
eventually would find out was the
prosthetic I'm like oh it's looks all
gross taurine and bloody blood-borne to
know all this thing is cool to get any
so holy crap the things yeah there's
that treasure chest right back I'll be
right back
there is no PvP in this game there's
none of the antagonistic stuff from Dark
Souls and blood-borne in this it's all
supportive co-op
so you can either run with an NPC buddy
or you can run with an NPC buddy and a
human usual ready but you cannot invade
region activation factory able to pick
that up region activation factory isn't
that the thing that gives you more of
the know that was something else maybe
this one makes them more potent enhances
okay yeah well there's got to be a boss
this way too right so right there it has
to be a third one
poor guys
you see
okay boy big boy Oh God
problem the heavy sound for my game nice
I'm almost dead I wonder if I can I got
two daggers if I do
restorative offering does the health go
to you I got some help thanks I wish
there was a spell that you can use to
heal like in Dark Souls and blood-borne
how they have like something usually
tied to faith to heal yourself oh yeah
just keep running out of the healing
items I see a fall gate I don't
so I guess that'll be a surprise for me
you can't die here
I don't either really clueless in this
game I know lighting a bunch of people
like right next to them they just turned
away just minding their own business oh
oh is it just one of those things well
you're gonna to fight them on your own
no I'm not I'm running back here cuz I
have no heels and I'm low on health
maybe buy some new gifts I should
probably start doing more of that Oh
Queen I so yeah the first person the
first boss we fought all of her columns
like when we beat him we got his
berserker code which gives you like a
bunch of just super violent attacks and
stuff like that and just the ability to
take a bunch of stuff
how is the level design it's hard to say
considering we've only really played two
levels they seem pretty basic once again
it was a tutorial and this so it's hard
to say like what late game levels could
look like but like this for instance is
just there's three paths go to three
different paths beat the bosses at the
end of the paths and then we open a door
and then the tutorial area was pretty
much just a circle almost yeah pretty
much
but like it like who said it's early on
maybe things get more complex later on
but as of now level design is not too
interesting or exciting there are like
they do they do try to trick you like in
Dark Souls like they'll hide enemies in
corners and stuff like that yeah but
sometimes your NPC partner will be like
have we found everything or look out or
something like that so they kind of have
a semi useful warning system a little
[Music]
that's reckless abandon can you know get
Louise Lewis Greece's attack decreases
damage reduction and alter colleges
all right I've done any of these
communal gifts no I've not gonna try the
Berserker though any of theirs you can
go now yeah there's the story area which
is super easy so we're not gonna show
that when you beat a boss you get his or
her power well it seems like we kind of
got them for beating the first boss yeah
I got a new blood sure if that's the
case for every boss alright should I
join you this time alright I mean are
you okay with fighting like probably
those two bosses over yeah that's fine
wait did you beat the I didn't beat the
Queen Slayer you know I didn't beat the
Queen slow ok we should fight the
Queen's they have to actually
go up online and you can set a password
if you wanna find friends quicker yeah
we did mess with that a little bit but
it doesn't seem too many people playing
xbox so you just join this way yeah
all right should we run past the enemies
enemies yeah I mean we have to like get
the ones I'm here to kind of run out at
us to run past bad idea
how'd that work no that idea oh I think
they're sending me home too huh well I'm
still searching so you could yes all
right
don't enter the boss area did what you
gonna do little doggy what you're gonna
do you rat nothing you got nothing
yeah just can't get past that area okay
leveled up quickly
all right
she's in it with magic I did demonstrate
my skills nicely right
the real thing still wants to hit me oh
never mind
oh my god yeah
that moves kind of brutal
it's just teleporting everywhere stop it
let me hit you no let me hit you that
did it that did it I need to heal I need
to heal badly I keep missing him I'm not
healthy because this sword wind up is so
slow
well we got him over half why is the
game just going to rely on me if then
the boss can just attack me immediately
I almost kind of wish it was like the
sechura where you could decide when you
wanted to revives you can like let the
boss kind of like walk away yeah a
little bit before you just pick yourself
back up
well no one got kicked at least due to
network that's that's good that lunge
attack is cheap yeah that one that's
kind of brutal
I made your mistake
oh shoot are you by there I'm dead well
I mean if you die enough times you can
always just like spawn on me here that's
what I'm gonna do
this dude wears his jacket and one of my
least favorite anime like stereotypes
things everywhere he's like having the
sleeves just blanketed over a show them
like why why even have the jacket then
it does nothing for you except get in
the way I like my characters cape I
think it's pretty cool I don't think
it's the best armor set I have but I was
like you know it looks cool all right
you carry you know I don't think so
did a lot of damage basically the second
he pulls back his sword I just dodged to
the side like fast enough oh right when
I decide to heal he's like nope
goodbye no it looks like your teammates
can't pick you up but they can't heal
you but I think you sacrifice some of
your own health in order to give it them
Amazon has the release date is December
yeah a lot of times when a game doesn't
have a release date Amazon will just
autofill yeah for December so don't
necessarily believe that who knows it
could have a December release date in
the end but usually when Amazon says
December it's just placeholder I think
this game was originally going to come
out in September 2018 so I guess so
totally see it coming out in September
October now 2019 this is to play offline
news online we were just sitting next to
each other I'm gonna see if I can use
that oh cool use it whatever I think we
just couldn't use it when we were on
like you know that makes sense
it's like Neos who never ended hey hey
[Laughter]
only you could Mercurio kind of that
attack I know all right
Socorro has ruined me for other souls
likes no I should replay that game no I
shouldn't replay that game don't you
have every achievement in that game yep
you're done if you tried the other boss
the one that we haven't fought yet sure
I'm going to switch to the thing I'm
used to though okay all right
sprint
I think this is the way following you
keep dodging mystical Misha says hi
everyone hello oh my gosh you wife who's
in the game
yes you can some might argue that that
is the highlight of this no matter I
give up the whole point of the game you
have so many enemies Fraulein you know
oh there's two of them what got a
critical strike and I yeah help me out
well I forgot to change my blood code
and means I have my heavy attack stuff
set
oh no I don't I've got the right thing
set Oh God
oh I think I finished this guy
backstabbed him nice tackle
yeah I like this guy cuz he staggers a
lot huh
he just knocks him down he is like the
best buddy
Oh area effect nice stagger look at that
first try is our first time playing that
boss I swear easy although we've had
plenty of practice against that one we
got to Queens steel though I think I can
upgrade my sword again and a reagent
activation factor right you can't use a
lot all right
don't forget to get this map Thing Thing
yeah I mean I guess you don't need to
have already beaten the boss Masseria
importance I didn't use any of my heel
stuff yep there I go
I just have a wallet
shoot him I guess I can join you coming
from Bach but actually I won't come from
behind them all
Wow all right uh should we try to beat
the other two bosses on your yeah on
your save bauxite says howdy hey how's
it going
see they found the bug yeah and we're
here to exploit it
all right I'll follow you sorry Ryan or
not I guess I'm faster should we run
yeah let's run friend I would say no
except I could get kicked any second now
come on our buddy's trying to fight them
good luck
we got enemies
I don't think you compare these guys I
did it on accident last night I think
weapon upgrading an armor yeah it seems
like you can upgrade all that stuff all
right that guy's done
this poor fool doesn't stand a chance Oh
with the backstab what is hard I like to
think so
easy can we go for three for three and
one run should we try
I didn't use any heel stuff knew this
you all right let's go I think I got my
heel stuff back so I healed twice during
that fight okay
maybe for beating it you get it back
alright these dudes yeah they're all
here Oh No sprint it away he's after you
he's a P seems like the dual bosses are
easier than the single bosses uh yeah I
guess that kind of seems like the case I
think it helps that there are three of
us so like even if they're focused on
two enemies or two of us there's a third
one who can kind of like what I pretty
much did that whole fight was just no
one focused on me so I was just getting
behind him all right he was like both of
my heels right here now should we run to
the next area all right let's do it
hopefully I'll get kick so we can
actually I meant full health I think
it's fine
watch how you got someone coming from
behind
this dog just keeps going for me running
running from the blood magic all right
I'm gonna run to
not good good he's gonna charge
just wail on him I got to get away in
he'll know we have no revives can I
revive oh I did and then I died you're
done you're hardly doing any damage I'm
so under level what level are you think
I'm 32
oh shoot I'm almost level 50 you have a
little 48 all right maybe you should
join my game why don't we do one more
run at that boss but in my game and then
we'll call it sounds like
oh I just hit how long okay I cannot
send or search for distressing weird
who knows what's waiting through here
locked
what's max-level no idea hey what's the
max level in Dark Souls I don't know I
think it's like pretty high up there
you're still able to yeah weird
yeah maybe rest yeah
I'll cancel mine too yeah huh
maybe load back to the home base or
whatever okay low it's green so it's
greens up to my game for a bit
there will be lots of looting oh I was
still sending out a distress signal
that's why no alright well so a lot of
loading ahead of you
Dark Souls ad circles love what camp is
80 maybe one or actually I don't know
maybe I know in blood-borne I got way
further than 80 like 370 something or
something insane its online co-op
because I think the fights rough time so
the people want to see I say I am still
loading
how are we liking the game so far yeah
there are things I like about it there
are things I don't like about it it's
not my favorite Souls like that I play
it yeah
I like it I might buy it I'd wait for
reviews and stuff just because this is a
very small slice of the game yeah I used
to see what the other levels are like is
the original area was very short and
very easy yeah and like part of the
reason this has been so hard is because
initially we were still under leveled
all right I will send it as dressing
weird is it still not
still no luck yeah for whatever reason I
mean I could just exit the game and load
it back up yeah I mean I could just try
this last boss the streams on meaning I
could try the last boss if we can call
it yeah I can I don't think I'll beat it
nah I believe in you you just have to
dodge it's a lunging attacks and you're
good
here's my thing from forever ago they're
called hex yeah keep attacking him
forget I'm here yeah that's what I'm
talking about keep attacking them okay
that makes sense rampant Lucky's Dark
Souls 3 might have a max level about 60
okay way more sense because I think I've
I was like level 100 in like 43
see your corner the way they're just
always stay behind him smack the booty
Dark Soul stuff so I game playing so far
Oh God how's this compared to the neo to
alpha the actual tutorial level was much
easier than neo to tutorial open lovely
but I really like neo
so I might be biased against it
I never played one oh shoot
that's what I heard where's my teammate
[Music]
definitely does that dark CIL's thing
where I get significantly more
aggressive that move is brutal
I cannot react quick enough well we beat
two of the three bosses for you I think
that's pretty good I don't know we got
to beat the last one max so level is 999
but anyway thank you guys for stopping
by this has been code vain like I said
don't know when it's coming at us what's
going on 2019 hopefully soon it's not
coming to switch at least it hasn't been
announced for switch but it's coming to
PC Xbox one ps4 and yeah I think that's
about it thank you guys as always for
tuning in and we'll be back next week at
11:00 am bye bye see ya